so this is the last session of the day
and right after we're going to also have
the temple right here so stay after
nicostoc to also discuss about reading
groups in other events
4 25 yes okay
hopefully we won't go over
okay so
we what we just discussed was that
there's this type of an incompatibility
between two different notions of regret
the external and the stackleberg because
they're optimizing for a different thing
so i just want to sort of wrap up that
by
saying that what that's really telling
you is that it's important you know
which world you're in because you
actually you cannot just commit to one
of these algorithms
sorry if you are coming to one of these
algorithms you need to know the world
you are implementing these algorithms
is the world where it's strategically
reacting to you or is it a world that's
not
because if you mismatch the world with
an algorithm you're going to end up
in the
wrong wrong way so somewhat there's no
best of the best of both worlds and the
worst case
okay um
and another thing i wanted to say is
that it does help and i talked about
this couple times but i think it's nice
to write it down
that
i could write zuckerberg regret as just
external regret for this other function
this f of p of t
it's just that this f of p of t itself
is is not a nice function
but it's something i could so i could go
between these two notions by just
changing the actual function
and nevertheless it's nice to think
about this because we can now talk about
the challenges that we face and in
general we need to face in terms of
these functions
rather than thinking about games and
strategies and all of that
so stackover regrets with respect to the
function class f defined this way is
equivalent to external regress
of uh
the yesterday sorry external regret
defined for ft is equal to stack over
defined for u
okay for the u1
um
so there are two challenges the first of
them
is that
this ft itself is um not
doesn't have structures that we
typically identify as nice structures
like it doesn't have complexity
concavity necessarily but it does happen
to be structured nevertheless like piece
by structure so
if you do forget about
all of this new and you want to think
about f
nevertheless you need to remember that
you want to use uh structures that are
non-typical outside of game theory
perhaps
and the other is that the partial
information we
thought about talked about uh membership
oracles or these best response oracles
and those are type of partial
information what i mean is that
if at one round i know the value of my
fcpt
i don't necessarily know what that
function fc is on everything else i
cannot do that kind of a computation
which
regrets that we were talking about
yesterday
you could have done because yesterday
you would see the instance and then you
could have known how good any of your
other predictors would have been
right now you cannot know how good other
options would have been
so this is typically referred to as
bandit except that
here we have more than bandit
information it's not that we just
observe what
the value the utility we observe
but that we see the action
and this best response is a little bit
more information than that
so what we need to do is to now think
about how do i design these exploration
algorithms that
use the best response
and help with the structure of this
optimization together
okay
guys i thought for a second i was
hallucinating
okay
so when you get here
uh so bandit's
assumption is that you only see the
value of the thing you play
now this best response gives you a lot
more information
and in particular
um
think about binary search a little bit
if it's half in your space in some sense
it's actually telling you if this would
have been higher or lower oh so
it does have a lot more power
um for the specific type of structure
that we're actually working with
there are uh
yeah if you're interested in this i did
not put this paper up but it's a
paper point in dc
uh 2015
that
actually talks about the exploration
basis for these uh
these algorithms and that's something
that you might want to look at it
specifically talks about how to use best
response to form these things that are
called very centric basis low variance
sort of exploration basis
okay so
the last part of this section before we
talk about collaboration is the question
that many of you asked which was
um
you hinted at asking which was
what is exactly happening in terms of
commitment who is committing to what
especially i'm talking about in a
repeated way
um what does it even mean to add every
time commit to something new
and sort of what we were thinking about
right then was that well the reason was
okay to think about
an immediate instantaneous best response
was that you were dealing with a myopic
adversary myopic follower
who is just trying to do the best
possible that's exactly why you would
just respond
but now we're gonna see whether or not
this makes sense first of all and what
happens if you're
in learning situations where people
actually do know that the learner is
learning something from their
observations
so those are non-myopic examples the
right sharing example
is one you know i i know that immediate
that are at least i hope that
by not participating or changing the
supply and demand i'm actually
impacting the statistical aspect of the
algorithm and getting a different type
of solution perhaps immediately
after so those are situations that we
have
a non-myopic agent
and
when you think about that
in some sense i started today's talk by
telling you how it's great to commit and
honestly like
yeah okay yeah
i wasn't giving you a life lesson but
it is great to comment you know
perhaps in life and
now and now
but
but then
i gave you algorithms that
specifically did not
i gave you algorithms that they explored
they tried a bunch of different things
and they were exactly the opposite of
commitment
so
it's really no surprise that sort of
commitment and online learning
specifically but learning in general
they go against each other one of them
is asking for stability while the other
one is asking for exploration
and
this is quite problematic because we
started thinking about commitment
because we thought it's doing better
than not committing
and uh
we want to be able to recover that both
in terms of
making sure that our settings make sense
but also making sure that we are getting
algorithms that we claim like in terms
of the util their utility is like great
about um it's actually meaningful in
terms of cycle berg equilibrium
so non-myopic agents these are agents
who are optimizing
over both past and future
and sort of you can think about them as
participating in an infinitely repeated
game
and these are the ones who are problem
for us
why are there a problem
they're problematic because of this
cycle that goes between the leader and
follower
let's say that the leader is trying to
actually learn okay so it's to learn
it's not committing
and now the follower
who knows that the learner is learning
can sort of be a little bit more patient
or
essentially send out some garbage
signals um
and the hope that you know what i'm
infinitely playing this game it's okay
if i lose for the next 10 rounds from
round 10 to infinity i'm gonna gain
and if the algorithm the leader knows
that this is happening well the
algorithm says okay i'll ignore the
first 11 rounds and then i start paying
attention
so
this type of um essentially
a free
channel for
taking actions that have no visible
impact on one's utility long-term
utility
can allow for something that's called a
cheap talk this is like essentially two
agents just talking to each other
neither of them mean what they're saying
and neither of them are taking actions
that actually change their behav their
long-term utility
and this inhibits learning
because it can just it doesn't matter
what the real life is until infinite
infinity you can talk about an imaginary
life
so
that's the problem and to talk about
this problem i'm going to actually talk
about a very recent and ongoing work of
mine i was trying not to include ongoing
works because the preprint for this is
not available but it's coming out in
like 10 days hopefully so if you want
the pre-print let me know but otherwise
i'm just going to give you a little bit
about overview of it because i think
it's a really interesting line of work
to be thinking about
okay so
the typical thing when we talk about
infinitely repeated games
part of it to get around this type of
internet cycle
it's pretty standard to talk about
two settings
one is that one of these agents is
getting discounted utilities so that
they cannot like any time that they're
sending some garbage signal
it's going to
be a
loss of opportunity for them
the other one is something called the
large market assumption which is which
says that actually
it's not that the same agent keeps uh
reappearing and i'm dealing with the
same agent who's instantly patient
but that
i'm seeing new people most of the times
it's just a person comes and sticks
around for like 10 days and then they
move on
um
you can make that assumption for either
of the players but we're just going to
make it for the follower this is a very
standard assumption reinforcement
learning in many other settings as well
and it allows us to actually
think about
long-term utility and now talk about
optimization of that long-term utility
as something that's not necessarily
infinite but something that you could
actually
approximately optimize so now
with that we can think about followers
that don't necessarily best respond
instantaneously at least
but they have these long-term strategies
that account for both past and present
and they're choosing these
strategies using policies
in a way that they optimize their
long-term utility an expectation
what that looks like is some discounting
factor gamma to the t
let's ignore that for now
and the sum of their utilities
of course the expectation is calculated
based on what they think the algorithm
is doing
and what the if they expect the
algorithm will do in the future rounds
given what their own policy is
so it sort of accounts for
the
progression of the algorithm as a
response to what they have done
in the past
and
are going to do in the present and are
going to do in the future
so this is what it means it's a little
bit complicated but luckily we never
actually have to uh exactly compute this
it just says that
um
the agents are long-term optimizers and
the point of having this discount factor
is that
if the discount is large enough
at some point you'd rather make
instantaneously semi-optimal
actions rather than hoping until the
infinity time
to get some additional utility from
having misled the learner
okay
now what is commitment here
commitment there's two notional
commitments there's of course the stack
of work type you're talking about that
around your strategies committed in a
verifiable way but actually the
algorithm itself
is now a medium of commitment
in the sense that
before this optimization starts the
algorithm has been committed to
um
and now what you want to talk about is
that what are some principled approaches
to designing this algorithm
so that even when the algorithm is
responded to in such and such pay
we're going to end up with a good
cycleback regret
this is the other side
yeah so that's exactly what it means the
conditioning on the algorithm it means
that they they're responding to the
algorithm but it's a policy
sorry
they will follow
yes it means that they're going that's
the algorithm that's so that's
implemented like they know and these are
usually long term if somebody deploys an
algorithm in real life there's actually
some stickiness to that algorithm
okay
so
as a principle there are many ways to
actually design such and such algorithms
but i want to give you some few
principal ways of thinking about it
okay
so
i'm going to use the fact that an agent
is discounted
by saying that
even without doing anything additional
the cheap talk is not so cheap anymore
because
discounted utility means loss of
opportunity
because if you didn't best respond
instantaneously
you're going to be losing some utility
right now
and it's not clear if you're going to
gain too much of it
there's a question
yeah um
[Music]
so your algorithm shouldn't be
deterministic
your algorithm should be designed
functions that you have and then this is
com factor
learning for example reset prices in
auction
so i'm just wondering
how does this distinct release to the
kind of the work station
i will mention them it's a different so
the way i think about this is that we're
actually giving you that's why i was
saying principled approach we're going
to give you a reduction
that works
for reserve prices it's going to work
for zuckerberg it's going to work for
any principal agent scenario
and we're going to just say that if you
are going to use this reduction so
it's kind of a general framework
what is it you want that to reduce to
that's kind of the question we're going
to ask so what is rather than actually
designing these algorithms these
algorithms have been designed and i'll
give you some citations
these algorithms have been designed in
the past but sort of if i didn't want to
keep designing them i just wanted to
sort of have the framework to reduce to
them what would that framework
okay
so
so as i said even the existence of uh
discounted utility is
is not letting the
it's making the follower be a little bit
more cautious about when it's not best
responding because it's losing uh
utility in those rounds
we can actually control the rate of this
we can make this loss bigger or smaller
but controlled by controlling the flow
of the information
between the learner or the leader and
the follower
so what i would think about is that
algorithm that i was saying if you want
to design a framework you can think
about you have an algorithm on this side
and you're not going to change the
algorithm much
what you're going to do is actually
change the information set of the
algorithm or how that algorithm is going
to be used
and
this flow of information is something
that you could turn up or turn down and
then you can talk about how you would do
this
the idea is that by putting this wall
you're encouraging approximate best
responding because you're making the
cost of this loss opportunity high
but you also cannot make this uh too
strong because you still need to make
sure that their algorithms on this side
they can that can learn despite this
wall that you've put up
so what kind of walls you're going to
put up
a natural type of wall that you can
think about perhaps the most natural
is
the one that delays information
it's the one that works very nicely as
nicely as possible
with these
discounted utilities
and the idea is that for large enough
delay the total expected gain in the
future is going to be small and that's
why you're going to get something that
looks like
almost best response
now
what does it mean it doesn't mean that
for from the leader's perspective it
looks like a best response what it means
is that
from the follower's perspective it
looked like a best response
so the follower didn't lose that much by
not having played the best response
of course this is going to have a
different type of um
impact on the leader's utility
but it usually comes with guarantee of
some sort
of closeness between
oh i'm noticing a mistake between
u1 of pt qt and u1 of pt br of pt
sorry i've made it blue which usually
means liter in my slides but i didn't
change 2 to one so those are leader
utilities
um
and this would have been the utility if
we really saw the best response
okay
now
in finite games example i gave you
before
this is going to look very structured
in fact in any finite game i'm giving
you an example of security here
what that says is that the utility the
utility of the leader is going to be
accurate far from off the bank far
enough from the boundary
and near the boundary there is no
guarantee for it it could be arbitrarily
bad estimation of it
and you can control how close
by changing how good this wall is
that's one example
there are other examples where this
closeness is a different notion of
closeness yes so i'm confused about
how the delay of these steps
you know
helps us
guarantee this
okay
so let's look at this line because this
line is the very first thing
so what did delay think so
what is it i want to see i want to see
the best response this is the best thing
that this minute that the follower could
have done
if it's not doing that
if this is a follower who is trying to
gain its max utility over infinitely
many time steps because it's discounted
utility that is a finite amount
okay
and by
by making it less and less likely
that his immediate information is going
to have any impact in the near future
not far future just near future
i'm saying that he's not going to gain
anything right now until the next 15
times sets if he's going to see any
gains it's going to be after 15 time
steps
and the gain after 15 time steps is
discounted so much that he's not going
to actually see much gain
this is kind of like saying that
in the in the ride sharing
i want to be able to not waste my time
more than half an hour sitting around
because it's better for me to drive
around
right now rather than sitting around for
half an hour so if i delay the
information that's coming from the
writers and drivers
i don't update my model immediately but
i update them later
i am discouraging them from trying to
manipulate this so quickly
that's
the high-level idea
so one way to think about is if it was
completed this content would have become
a single step
this wall is saying that i can go
between
uh
between myopic to fully non-myopic
essentially
by changing how fast the information
comes in because if i delayed infinitely
long
then
i have
borrowed my algorithm from seeing any
information but it's all very compatible
there's no reason for that do they know
exactly
um can you make it a random thing you
can make it a random thing it's not a
problem they know the algorithm and
delay is a feature of this algorithm so
either they need to know it or they need
to know where the distribution has come
does this
so
so they don't actually
get the signal
on the spot
so inside their friends there are
algorithms that asynchronous
there's this concept of delay more
generally when you take an action
at some point in the future you get an
observation but you don't know if that
observation was for this time step or
next time or whatever
this is easier than that because my wall
can tell you where what time the
observation occurring
so it actually
gives you more uh much more information
and freedom and because of that because
you can design the wall you can get
better better rates than those
algorithms that have to work for
adversarial delays
all right so anyway once you get this
type of approximate best response then
that approximately this response is
going to have some impact on you
and for this example the approximate
best response is only uh wrong
essentially far from the boundary
because if you're close to the boundary
those are the areas that the follower
would have not cared to go which way one
to the other
but then you're far from it now he does
care
so what do we want from the algorithms
behind this wall now um
let's write the list of them uh the
first thing is that
well i want to be able to actually this
algorithm should optimize
uh from banded observations so even if
it was fully myopic it should be able to
optimize from these banded observations
that we talked about in the previous
section
but it also has to be robust to some
specification on this function
in particular the example i gave you was
the one that said the the
this function was off only in a very
small structured areas near the
boundaries
but there are also some other examples
like in strategic classification it
happens to be point where it's close
everywhere but not exactly the same
there are different notions of being
robust in an adversarial way and they
usually get put here
and the last thing i want is that the
algorithm needs to be able to handle
debates somehow
and the first two are actually things
that we understand pretty well
for myopic agents anyway i have to be
able to solve problem number one so
that's
somewhat the bare minimum i needed to do
when i'm done
number two is also something that is
pretty well studied
in the sense that the algorithm i gave
you for example the least support of
paper
comes already with these these
optimizations that are robust to
membership query being sort of wrong
uh near the boundaries and the for
point-wise closeness again this is
something that either exists already or
it's not very hard to design kind of
like designing algorithms that are
robust adversaries is a whole field
that's pretty important and
studied a lot
now how do you design algorithms to
handle delays that's part of the
question
and in fact i'm going to say that while
i'd like to think about the wall as a
delay
it's actually
it's easier to think about it in a
completely different framework that's
much more studied than business
and this is a framework of what's called
batch bandits
so one way to think about batch bandits
is that um
you have an algorithm that has to submit
queries and batches so even though i
have these timelines sort of all of the
queries in this line are submitted
together and i see the answer to all of
them only after my batch ends
same i submit all the green queries and
only see the answers after so this is a
type of batch bandit i don't get any
feedback in the middle of my batches
the reason i like to think about this is
that this is more common in optimization
and it's a feel that people have thought
about so their algorithms
we understand their rates better
now delays are actually equivalent to
batches in the sense that
you could think about if you have an
algorithm that could deal
with batch sizes he can actually go
around and get one that can deal with
delays
and vice versa with only a constant
actually a factor of two gap between the
regrets they're going to achieve
now this really just allows us this kind
of characterization allows us to
to use both literature there are
algorithms that are much easier to
handle and deliver are algorithms that
have been studied in the batch version
for a long time
but this is a nice way of thinking about
again in a principal way how do we go
about designing these algorithms
so really if i go back to this algorithm
what i'm saying is that
i'm looking for robust background
without work if i have a robust
background algorithm
everything i did would plug it plug into
them
and has this kind of a reduction
that makes any robust batch granite
algorithm
affected in presence of non-biopic
agents
so that's kind of the high level ideas
and i don't want to go into this a lot
but
kind of in
we've shown that like in three most
common applications this is very easy to
put together because robust patch rather
that would either were not to exist
or we can actually introduce them
so for multi-arm bandits we introduce uh
some nice ones specifically
and that that works really nicely for
any discretized set so like for auctions
for example
uh for demand learning and a bunch of
other problems all together fall in that
really nicely
and uh they get really nice sort of
additive delay bounds rather than
getting um multiplicative delay bounds
as you know
um in terms of the lp i already told you
that the algorithm i i gave you actually
comes with some nice guarantees
and a bunch of other algorithms can also
be changed or already come with
guarantees like banded convex
optimization
comes with that kind of guarantee as
well
so this is just saying that if you want
to think about sort of the principles of
how to use data and how not to use data
thinking about this flow of information
and how you restrict it allows us to
actually reduce the problem to an
adversarial uh robustness type of
question in a field that's been studied
for quite some time so that's an
advantage of being able to really
actually
forget about these myopic non-myopicness
and
actually appeal to a different field to
solve these problems
there's a lot more on this so some of i
i put some of these uh
here especially for auctions uh there
are different ways to design the wall
another which has been definitely used
for incentive compatibility is
privacy as a tool
and
another paper that makes a really nice
case about kind of thinking about
algorithm as a medium of commitment
is this one that kind of talks about um
reactiveness like in some sense it's
also about how fast you update your
algorithm
which you could have thought about uh
about it in the delay or batch version
as well
so that's it for the non-myopic part um
if there are questions
we can take a minute to ask questions
yeah
[Music]
and making sure that whatever your
algorithm
i'm stopping from being your
responsibility
are there presents can you comment on
this nation's cheap talk like in the
game
yeah okay
so
okay so let me first
okay so there's a lot to be said and
there's a lot that we don't know
so
first of all the way that we're getting
out of cheap talk is of course by making
things costly right
and that that's the typical way to get
out of cheap talk the other thing is
that the way i talked about this um
algorithm is slightly different than the
gate direct notions of like
like
uh down the road
so
there's not my difference between them
and
the other difference
i think easier to tell me the
differences
is that
um
for
several like full theorem style
arguments um
the amount of discounting needed is more
of a technicality it's like it could be
like originally possible
but to actually get regret downs you
cannot allow the studio to be close to
one so there is a limit and we do
understand more about some um
relatively well and certain like in
options we understand above
uh and options are very simple often you
understand as well and that tells us
kind of a rate in terms of um
how much
cost you have to induce on people
before you can uh
get these long-term limits
um
you're essentially you have to go around
the whole team otherwise everything
would have been an equilibrium so both
the definition and everything is
trying to get around that
okay
so
in the next half an hour
i'm going to
talk probably faster
um
and i'm going to talk about
collaborative interactions
yes
so these are definitely about two
players um we haven't even thought about
more than two
because we have to sort of real like
like this is as i said it's like a stack
over a game on top of the stack of our
game and it's not exactly a subgame
perfect equilibria so i'm not even sure
how i would define it from one actually
um what was the second question
uh games
um
we're already dealing with bandits
when you don't know the status
yeah so what i meant is that we are
already doing with dealing with bandits
and per time allowing this ft to be a
different function so i imagine as long
as you can find the batch under that
button for it
it's quite general in that sense at
least
okay
so for collaboration um
this is uh
i would say i would argue that this is
the newer part of not just this tutorial
but also the efforts of the community
um
so
i'm going to try to get across some very
interesting questions
but also questions that aren't as well
understood uh hoping that we can spend
some of the semester actually talking
about some of these questions because
i'd love to chat
so to do that at first i'm going to
actually talk about models for
collaborative learning what i mean when
i talk about collaboration and machine
learning
then i'll talk a little bit more about
aspects about how do we think about a
single agent versus
sort of social benefits
and then i'll talk about more about
rationality in equilibrium
so
to
start taking a closer look at what
collaboration is
um collaboration and cooperation in
computing in general is like it's very
general term and it's used in
a lot of different domains
uh for example a lot of times we think
about collaboration as like a
multi-agent interaction coordination of
sort of how we take some decisions to
act
but there is also this view um that
um
[Music]
that collaboration is not just about the
decision that we're taking but also
about sort of
sorry what's happening
okay also about the
informations we are gathering
so it's not just about hey how do i like
split the utility of actions that we're
taking
but actually
how do we coordinate to increase our
information set
in ways that are and then make decisions
based on them
so that's the view that i want us to
have going into this talk
and the reason for this is that
there's more and more of course you're
having more data but also are having
more stakeholders in the sense that the
data is spread across a lot of different
sources
um
and these different sources uh are not
necessarily like data centers they're
actually people like
agencies that hold the data so they
might have completely individualized and
heterogeneous learning objectives
but they're also going to
potentially have other objectives that's
not about learning but more about the
use of their data
so this is why more and more data
sharing is becoming important there are
whole fields in compute and machine
learning called like like the fancier
keyboard sorry what's happening
huh okay
it seems like
my slideshow wants to just continue
myself
um
give me one second i think i have a
i've recorded this in the past
okay
um
and data sharing what it's trying to do
is it's trying to enable large number of
learning agents to collaboratively
accomplish their learning goals and from
collectively fewer resources and these
resources are typically
computation and data and we're going to
focus a lot more on data
and it's starting to be used across
networks of devices and hospitals and
it's been also behind some major
scientific breakthroughs actually this
ability not what are the learning but
the ability to share data in ways that
benefits both individuals and the
society
so the whole idea is that if you're
trying to create this large-scale impact
we also need large-scale participation
and
lower scale part participating
participation
is going to mean that we are going to
have to recruit agents and also retain
them which means that the incentives
needs to be much more aligned for people
to want to participate and participate
fully
in our protocols
so part of this is making sure that we
are meeting individual learning
guarantees
what does this mean
well let me give you an example from
federated learning algorithms because
these are algorithms that were designed
to work well on average over data
centers that's usually the data sources
were
believed to be data centers
of course they've changed now a little
bit but so the basic
idea about them is that they're good for
learning across these data centers
and
that means that it's actually pretty
good when these data sources are quite
homogeneous it's the same data it just
was split sort of randomly across
different sources
but when it comes to either human or
organizational data
we don't have homogeneous data anymore
we have very heterogeneous data and for
heterogeneous data
the average becomes meaningless because
you might have average of five percent
on average but that just means that for
ten percent of people you have an
average of like fifty percent you have
an accuracy of fifty percent
so we don't want to have these on
average performance guarantees
but we also know that on average
performance guarantees are coming
with a lot less effort so
how can we sort of think about
trying to get pair agent guarantees but
still control the amount of efforts
so if we actually look at some standard
um
runs of standard algorithms
what we see is that let's say that this
is 70
this is when the average is 70
then to hit an average 70 percent every
agent has to use an amount of data set
and amount of iterations that's
relatively small
but if i want to continue the same
algorithm without designing a new
algorithm until each one of them means a
minimum accuracy of 70
now every single one of them actually
has to do more work it's not that those
other people stopped earlier
but that everybody actually has to be
part of the system for much longer
and this is not something that makes
sense for a lot of agents that have to
pay both for computation and data
so what we really want here is that can
we ensure that every learning agent has
high accuracy
but still make sure that it's from
reasonably small amounts of data
individually from them
so
let's give a slightly more
theoretically grounded model for this
this is from a paper we had in north
four years ago
i'm going to tell you my father what it
means you could define it in terms of
variance but i'm actually going to talk
about high probability
um
okay so what is it that mathematically
we want we say that assuming that there
are k populations these are you know
distributions and what you want is that
uh you want to learn a function that's
good and goodness is defined by the
worst error so the error of the worst
hundred worst population or the worst
person for the worst organization and
say that you want to have this to be
more and lesser
and then the question is how much data
suffices for every learner to achieve
this high accuracy through collaboration
it's not surprising that collaboration
must need interaction because that's how
we define collaboration
but it's good to think about what
collaboration what interaction means
because the other algorithms i gave you
they were also interacting they were all
sort of collectively trying to
run some optimization on collective data
okay
so the trouble with the earlier
algorithms the standard earlier
algorithms are lack of interactions
and
really the idea here is that the number
of samples that a person where
a learner provides
their learning rates their update
frequency all of these are decided
non-interactively they are decided at
the beginning of time and never update
it
they never updated based on the
performance of other agents might be
updated on their own personal
performance not but not on a societal
performance
and you can actually show that if you
don't have these things being
interactively updated
then you're going to be stuck with a
type of sample complexity that is
essentially as bad as if nobody
collaborated at the first place you
started
what this is saying is that
the sample complexity of collaboratively
solving k problems is k times the sample
complexity of solving one problem so you
could have just as well told them each
of you just go solve your problem
so this is without an interaction
it's saying that collaborative learning
is almost as ineffective as not
collaborating at all
so
this is from which objective function
the one on your previous slide
the max error why does it have a
solution actually
like
because i'm making a simplified
assumption uh which is not necessary but
it just changes how we're defining
things
so i'm assuming that that's zero
i'm assuming that
max
error of the i
h zero
now i could have defined this as opt
and ask for opt plus epsilon
but i'm just assuming that this is zero
and one one place that this could have
been zero is when you have a target
classifier h star
that every distribution is labeled
according to the same classifier what
this means is
is that there is a ground fruit like
there's
the data is not that noisy or something
so the ground truth but we care about
different parts of this ground truth um
but that's an example but uh almost
everything i say you could do for you
know yeah
from your previous slides from
uh what's your definition of
heterogeneity for the results you're
presenting uh
i mean
that the one two decays are not the same
but uh with the exception of what i told
questions as well which was uh
for this purpose out there that h star
that would have labeled everything
okay
so
here and what i claim is that if you
allow for interactivity which really
just means that adjusting the amount of
sample
contribution and learning
then you can improve this k to
log of k
okay
now why is this the case i'm going to
make a case for this without proving it
but by talking about midnight theorem
but i see some puzzled faces already
are there questions about this
this is on offline learning
and one of the things i want you to take
away from this is that online algorithms
can be nice medium for
collaboration
but the problem itself is defined in an
offline way
an interaction can be enabled through
online algorithms that's
part of what i want you to think
okay
so
why should you believe this
well
you could really think about this as a
min max optimization in fact what i
wrote there is essentially saying that
the min max value is zero
and asking you to sort of approximate
give me a solution that's approximately
that
so if i look at this
i can really think about this now recall
we talked about two players solving a
min max game yesterday i can think about
having two players player one and two
and i know that if one of them plays
best response on the other plays in the
record algorithm on average what's going
to happen is that the average solution
is going to be
approximate min max equilibrium
and approximate maximum equilibrium
so that's exactly what i'm going to do
this is that i'm going to solve this
with a no regret algorithm
and one way to think about this is that
the rules are a little bit different
than yesterday whoever the person who's
playing no regret and the person who's
playing best responses swaps but doesn't
really matter
here player one is best responding what
it means is that player one is a
minimizer
and he's essentially running an erm this
is just an algorithm that finds the best
hypothesis on some sample
and what it's doing is that it's not
taking the samples according to uniform
distribution or any one person's
distribution is taking it according to
some distribution that's defined by
player two
now what is that distribution defined by
player two that's the job of player two
player two is a no regret learning agent
who's maintaining a distribution
over the k
learning agents themselves
and you can think about these as like
different weights alpha
k at time t
and these alphas are supposed to be a
proxy of how well or poorly uh
i have done so far in terms of
satisfying a good like coming up with
good classifiers for those agents so far
now what happens
um forget about this epsilon prime and
the corner but what i'm saying is that
well because i have a no regret
algorithm from the perspective of the
second player
there's some some of all these errors
that i have accumulated over the
distributions that player 2 defined
is
pretty close to
the sum of the errors for
the worst agent
that's what it means to be no regret
with respect to agents you're competing
with the worst agent in hindsight in
some sense
now if my erm algorithm at time pt takes
enough samples so that this error is
guaranteed to be small
then what i'm really saying is that hey
actually i am competing with
with this um
best worst case solution
so this is not actually giving you an
algorithm to actually get a good sample
complexity that i told you that log of k
blow up you you need to look at this a
little bit more closely you need to
actually design specific types of
algorithms for them but nevertheless
this shows you the main ideas
and now where did the log of k come from
i have k agents it's like i had k
columns and i'm doing best response over
k options
so we talked about little some dimension
now some dimension of something with k
is never larger than log of k
that tree had to the depth of the tree
can never be larger than the number of
things that are available under it so if
i have k things i cannot
have more than log k
and that's why even simple online
algorithms it doesn't have to be the
standard optimal algorithm even simpler
algorithms can get you that log of k
coming up
so that's a high level idea
and what
i want to really remember from this is
that
i'm not saying that this is the right
model or this is the right algorithm but
rather i think that we should think
about online learning as a medium for
actually designing protocols that are
efficient
we don't have a ton of time so let me
talk a little bit more about
another problem related which is
i think really interesting
um going beyond accuracy guarantees um
agents also have costs for collecting
information so this could be the cost of
curating the data set could be some
other
cost like privacy costs and we don't
want to have these protocols that are
asking for unreasonable amounts of data
and people have reasons not to want to
give a lot of data like an example of
this is that if you look at like
physical testing of for example water
pipes for lead
this is an expensive process and it sort
of ruins your backyard you have to
actually dig a hole it's not something
you want to do
but if you believe that whatever the
result is is going to be highly
correlated with your neighbor you really
wish that they would take the sample so
there's a little bit of you know these
types of incentives of how how much you
believe you have to actually participate
versus how much you benefit from it
those are questions that we need to
understand we need to achieve these
desirable per agent
type guarantees between accuracy and
sample
and
this tells us that we need to develop a
theory for multi-agent sample complexity
and i'm not going to tell you that we
already have one i'm just asking you to
participate in creating it
but let me give you
some
definitions that i think are interesting
so part of this is what is a reasonable
share of data
and the
things that are unreasonable is for
example if i have k agents
and i ask them
ask i to give me more data that is
necessarily strictly for i by himself to
learn that's just completely
unreasonable they shouldn't they
shouldn't have to pay more in
collaboration than they would
individually
another thing is that if part of ice
contribution in data
was used exclusively to increase the
accuracy for other agents but it didn't
actually had have a
significant increase in their own uh
in the accuracy of your own their own
task
and we formalized this in a recent paper
last year
uh by
uh by two notions uh individual
rationality
which is actually how it's defined in
economics in general
that's capturing the first type of
reasonable or unreasonable
contribution
essentially every agent has an accuracy
constraint that has to be met
for example if i think that each agent
is providing mi
samples
then i want that and their accuracy
constraint is met
with this
but if
they were to provide any
more
like this should be less than what they
would have needed
to solve this problem by themselves and
meet their accuracy constraints by
themselves
so if you want like 95 accuracy how much
data you would have needed by yourself
now i'm asking for less than that
perhaps getting new data is going to
make me uh
so actually so if you're looking at this
there's no reason to have competition
right now there are versions of this
competition but that is the
incentives are not misaligned so you're
assuming that their incentives are alive
i'm assuming that they're not misaligned
it's slightly different in the sense
that more data from other sources will
help me strictly more data from others
will never hurt me yes but what about
what about her
right is the person who's giving you the
data
exactly so that's exactly what we're
trying to capture
what you were saying that i'm willing
so whatever is going to make you
accurate but no more but maybe i don't
want to even make you like no no no
whatever is making me accurate
is that
both of these are me these are the same
agents
um i'm putting and a strict upper bound
per agent
and then i will give you something
more constrained but the strict upper
bound says that i imagine a world where
nobody was helping me
how much data of my tasks would require
now in any world that i collaborate i
should not give any more than that
it's very minimal
nothing fancy yes so uh
benefits
so right now i'm not actually defining a
protocol i'm defining uh
a collection
and i'm saying a collection has these
properties then i'll talk about
what am i optimizing given these
constraints
but don't believe that a sub-collection
is not better than the whole
no so in fact so right now this is just
about individual rationality it's not
about how you split
you know this it's not poverty game
theory in fact i'm going to give you
only non-cooperative game theory type
solutions let me give you one other
example because i know that we're
running out of time and i want there to
be enough things here so that we can
continue the conversation after
so the other is something i'm going to
call stable equilibrium it's analogous
to nash equilibrium
what this means is that um
i
this
uh amount of data
is stable at stable equilibrium if for
every agent
that agent could not have unilaterally
decreased their sample size or made it
smaller
what that means is that if i'm in this
collaboration and i'm taking a thousand
samples if i were going to only
contribute 900 i'm primarily hurting
myself
okay
so that's a more uh restrictive uh type
of um sort of
um
allocation
okay so then why do we care about these
of course there is a notion of welfare
for the agents we
started talking about what is reasonable
when it's unreasonable and they capture
this but it's also about the stability
and usability of the system because if
the system is not individually
irrational people are not going to sign
up for it
if it's not stable people are going to
keep trying to game it by giving it
different amounts of data and then you
don't know what's going to happen
sometimes if you take like current
algorithms
um you actually see that these
algorithms are pretty bad
for in terms of stability at least what
they're doing is that for more than 50
of the agents the agents would have
individually thought about decreasing
their sample sets
by like 20 volts which is pretty
problematic
now that we've defined these the
questions we want to ask are do these
notions actually exist individual
rationality always exists because you
can just pretend that nobody's
collaborating
but doesn't equilibrium exist
unfortunately not in some corner cases
but they do generally exist under
certain assumptions
the idea is that when they don't exist
it's because
somebody else was better at doing your
job
using their own data set and much much
much better than you are for doing your
own job
what do i mean imagine this is this is
not going to happen in real life but
just
think about such a situation
that i have three agents
and each of them has a data set
and sort of the labels of the first
person's data set
is uh encoding the functions that would
have worked perfectly for the next agent
so a single sample from the first
person's data set would have solved the
situation completely for the next
and so on and so forth but for
themselves they need to see at least one
point to be able to control their own
game
so what happens is that the first person
is going to sample
that means that the second person is not
going to need to sample
the the third person has to sample which
now means that this person's problem
would have been solved so this person
now doesn't want to sample
so there's this natural cyclic behavior
because it's actually very like much
closer to like we're asking for
something that's much closer to pure
strategy equilibrium and we don't have
continuous space and we don't have
continuous actions
and essentially the lack of continuous
space and action is the only thing
that's going to go wrong so i'm not
going to tell you when they do exist but
think about continuity
now are equilibrium efficient when they
do exist
this is similar to types of questions
that eva was asking the other day like
price of anarchy but now this is about
price of stability
of if i'm forcing myself to be
in a
in an equilibrium how much more samples
do i have to take
of course sometimes the equilibria don't
exist but even in most realistic
settings this is not very good
like one way to think about this is that
even if i had continuity and many other
aspects you can imagine a scenario where
i have one person whose data set is
intersecting everybody else's
but this means that both for rationality
actually and for equilibria
in the optimal setting if i don't care
about incentives the central person
should do no work because their problem
is strictly like solved but when
everybody else's problem is solved
but at equilibrium they should
um
sorry
at equilibrium they should do no work
because their problem is solved by
everybody else's problem but for the
optimal solution they have to do all of
the work there's a trade-off here the
person whose problem
is subsumed by other people's problem
happens to be also the person who is
most efficient at solving other people's
problem if they just overworked a little
bit more on their own problem setting
and this trade-off can show that you
actually do have a pretty large gap
between these solution concepts there's
a square root of k at least that we know
of
um
we don't quite understand these
equilibria well at all actually
but i think that one interesting thing
is that it also very much depends on the
shape of the error function of course if
this error function looked something
that was linear
then we find a very interesting
structural property
which is that sort of free writing this
thing that some people just do not
contribute at all happens and it has to
happen as part of an equilibrium
but it actually doesn't mess up anybody
else's game in the sense that if i think
about those people who are not
collaborating and i forget about them
everybody else is pretending to
collaborate in an optimal way with the
participating agents
so it's kind of nice to notice that in
many of these situations free writing
effect is more kind of a local effect
than a global effect
okay um
so what i really want here is that
i think we need a new mathematical
foundation for designing these learning
algorithms that act globally
but have to consider agent objectives
and incentives and we don't have one so
it would be nice if the semester
responds sometime on down
okay i'm out of time
so
this is what we talked about today and
yesterday
and sort of these were some of the
questions
we spent a lot of time on question one
actually yesterday these are all about
learnability
we and uh question one and two and two
today question two we also talked about
the principles of how to use it on how
not to use it of course we saw things
about collaboration and
one thing is that
as we saw like no regret online learning
actually played a role in everything
sometimes as an optimization
and achieving solution concepts but
other times also has some kind of a
medium for collaboration which i find
quite interesting
with that let me not take more of your
time and thank you for listening for
four hours
[Applause]
do you want me to take questions or to
do some questions yeah thank you so much
[ __ ] for this sure incredible tutorial
yeah if someone has a
yeah the question is that if you allow
for monetary transactions what happens
um
you can always allow for monetary
transactions and go to a different
solution concept okay
um
it doesn't mean that you are you're
gonna end up with high accuracy things
necessarily
uh
let me just say that i specifically
think non-cooperative um
just like that natural growth is a
non-problematic type of solution concept
there are solution concepts that are
more about cooperative
games and i'm happy to chat about them i
think they are inherently very different
from like you have to have a different
perspective on what the status are you
trying to achieve
okay thank you
so
um
it's time for all of you to speak up and
express your interest